تواجه العديد من العائلات السعوديه ازمه
في التواصل باللغه العربيه مع ابنائها حيث
نشا الاف من الاطفال السعوديين في بلدان
الابتعاد ما تسبب بقصور في فهم اللغه
العربيه واستخدامها للتواصل الى جانب
عائلات اخرى اتجهت لتعليم ابنائها في
المدارس العالميه التي تعتمد التدريس
باللغه الانجليزيه الامر الذي فاقم ازمه
اللغه الام لدى اعداد كبيره من الاطفال
تعليم الاطفال عمليه بالغه التعقيد
والحساسيه
التطور الكبير والتداخل المعرفي خلق حاجزا
كبيرا تجاه اللغه العربيه
يواجهه جيل من الطلاب في السعوديه سواء
كان ذلك بسبب مرافقتهم لعائلاتهم للخارج
بغرض الدراسه او حتى تسجيلهم بالمدارس
العالميه داخل السعوديه بعض هذه العائلات
تنبهت لحجم المشكله وبعضها لم ينتبه حتى
الان بعد ما عادوا المملكه
اللي قاعد خمس سنين اربع سنين سبع سنين
فالطفوله ابنائه كلها كانت
في الخارج يعني فكانت اللغه العربيه ليست
يعني
ليست حديث اليوم بالبيت يعني احس بالذنب
انه ابي ولدي يوصل هالمرحله ابغاه لما
يسمع بيت شعر او لما يسمع باب اولى مثلا
ايه قرانيه او حديث باللغه العربيه فيه
معاني ابغاويه يحس فيه زي ما انا احس فيه
يعني ما الذي استطيع ان نفعله كي كي نجد
حلولا لمساله الاغتراب اللغوي الان يجب ان
نقول منذ البدايه اللغه الانجليزيه مطلب
اتقان لغه اجنبيه عالميه هو اليوم كي نكون
واقعيين هو اليوم ضروري
ولازم وممكن جدا ليست بهذه القضيه الكبيره
وانما اللغه الام اتقان اللغه الام
اكتسابا وتعلما هو طبعا الاساس يرى مختصون
ان الحمل يقع على عاتق الجهات التعليميه
حيث ان مناهج اللغه العربيه
تفتقر لاساليب الجذب اللازمه بعكس
الانجليزيه عبد الرحمن الحضيف احد الاباء
الذين يعانون من هذه المشكله مع ابنائهم
حيث قرر اخيرا تاسيسا مبادره لتعليم
العربيه لتجاوز هذه المعطله احنا نشاطنا
مراكز اعمال
وهذا هيا مكان جاهز انه يطلق مبادره للغه
العربيه
فكان الفكره انه تواصلنا مع احد
الجهات والشركات المختصه في هذا المجال
وطلعنا باتفاقيه ان شاء الله تظهر للنور
قريبا كمبادره لاستخدام احد المراكز هذه
الاطلاق مبادره للغه العربيه
لان اللغه جزء من الهويه هكذا وصف احد
الاباء دوافعه لاعاده تعليم ابنائه اللغه
العربيه
بالرغم من المتاعب التي يواجهها اولياء
الامور بسبب تنشئه ابنائهم بعيدا عن اللغه
الام الا ان المحاولات قائمه داخل العديد
من الاسري لتدارك هذا الموقف العصير
من الرياض عبد الواحد الحميد العربيه
من استديوهات ايضا في الرياضيات
الباحث والاكاديمي في اللغويات التطبيقيه
في جامعه الملك سعود اهلا وسهلا حياك
دكتور خلني ابدا معك من مشهد لا يختلف
كثيرا عن محمد قاله الزملاء طبعا في
التقرير السابق مجموعه من طلاب احدى
المدارس العالميه زارتنا في قناه العربيه
معدله اعمارهم من سبع الى عشر سنوات كان
عندنا مشكله في التواصل معهم بشكل حقيقي
يتحدثوا باللغه الانجليزيه ولما جينا نجرب
معهم يعني قراءه نصوص على الوقت كيو كانت
همم يعني عندهم مشكله في قراءتها طلبوا
تغيرها الى اللغه الانجليزيه
هذا نتكلم عن حوالي 20 طالبه يمثلون واحده
من 1900 تقريبا او 2000 مدرسه عالميه
واجنبيه في الرياض تحت بس و 50,000 تقريبا
طالب وطالبه موجودين في هذه المدرسه هذا
جيل جديد هل نعاني من مشكله معهم
الحديث عن اهميه اللغه الام في التعليم
واثرها ايضا في ازدهار الثقافه والحضاره
هو امر محسوم تقريبا في الابحاث العلميه
حتى المنظمات الدوليه التي من صالحها ان
تروج اللغه الانجليزيه بان تكون لغه
مهيمنه مثل ما تسمى اللجنه مثل ما ذكرت
الزميلها الباحثه حول ذلك واهميه ضروره
اللغه الانجليزيه الا انهم يدافعون عن
اللغه الام بشكل كبير وهذا يعطي طيفا
وتنوعا كبيرا في العالم ويكون لكل مكان
لونه وثقافته الخاصه همم الزملاء او ال-
ال- الطلاب الذين زاروه العربيه وهذا
المشهد الذي وصفته للاسف هو مؤسف جدا هم
لم اااه
فقط من التحدث باللغه العربيه هم هنا
عذروا حتى عن الموهوب العربيه هم هنا عزل
حتى عن التراث العربي وحتى عن الارث
العربي وحتى عن الشعور والمشاعر اليوم انت
لو تقول لهم سم او لبيه لن تكون ابدا
وقعها مثل كلمه يس او اي كلمه مقابله لها
فبالتالي حتى اذكر مؤسسه لها مبادره جميله
سمتها سمات الشخصيه السعوديه من ضمن سمات
الشخصيه السعوديه وجدت ان اللغه العربيه
هي احد اهم ركائز هذه السمات لان صفات
الشعوب مجتنزه في لغاتهم فكلمه كرم وشهامه
لا يقابلها اي الترجمه في العالم لانها
تعبر عنكم مثل ما يقول بالجني ان اللغه
اصوات يعبر بها كل قوم عن اغراضه فاولئ
الطلبه لم يعبر عن اغراضهم بلغتهم وانما
بلغه غيرهم وهنا تكون المشكله هذه المشكله
للاسف بدات تتفاقم احد الزملاء تحت الهواء
قبل قليل ونحن نحضر بهذا يسالني يقول هل
هي بندر ظاهره اللي حصل في العربيه ذكرت
لا بانه كلمه ظاهره تحتاج
نزول الميدان الا لانه الحضارات والدول
المتقدمه في العالم تهتم لذلك وتصنع
مؤشرات وقد يكون اشهرها مؤشر كجان في مؤشر
قوه اللغات في العالم واثرها وكان فيها
نطاقات كبيره جدا ومؤسسه من المسؤول اذا
كانت هناك الكلام من المسؤول عنها مؤسسات
التعليم واحد المؤسسات التنشئه الاجتماعيه
في البلد ولا الاسر جميل هذا سؤال رائع
جدا وياتي كثيرا اعتقد انه المسؤول في
الطراز الاول هو مؤسسات التعليم والمؤسسات
الكبيره الافراد لا يستطيعون ان يقاومون
تيارا كبيرا هو يجرف الكثير من
الثقافات سواء على مستوى وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي او على مستوى الشبكه المفتوحه
او على مستوى الافلام وذكرتهم ايضا في
التقرير ان كل ما يقدم باللغه الانجليزيه
واكثر تشويقا الفيلم الانجليزي اكثر
تشويقا الروايه الانجليزيه اكثر تشويقا
الكتاب التعليمي باللغه الانجليزيه كثرت
شويقا فهذا التيار الكبير لا يصده الا
تيار نوعا ما مشابهه على الاقل على
المستوى المحلي بان يقدم اللغه العربيه
بترازيل الا يقدمها بالتطورات الشعبيه
القديمه لا بتقعر ولا بمبالغه في همم
التصح وانما لها جاءتنا الطبيعيه التي
نتحدث بها ونزهوا بها ونفخر وايضا اللغه
العربيه بشكل عام المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بتعيير هذا الامر اهتماما كبيرا
على مستوى التشريعات الماده الاولى من
النظام الاساسي للحكم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه دوله عربيه اسلاميه ذات سياده
تامه دستورها كتاب الله وسنه رسوله ولغتها
اللغه العربيه وعاصمتها الرياض 49 قرار
مجلس الوزراء وايضا قرارات ساميه كانت في
دعم اللغه العربيه الا انها اليوم لا
نراها للاسف على الميدان مسميات كثيره
تكون باللغه الانجليزيه سواء بمبادارات
كثيره احنا ذكرنا انه المشكله يمكن ان
طلاب الابتعاث اكبر من ناحيته كثير كان له
طلاب ايضا وهم في امريكا وفي اوروبا وفي
الدول اللي كانوا يعني الحديث في الداخل
البيوت هو باللغه العربيه ما وجهه اي
مشكله لما لما وصلوا الى ورجعه الى
المملكه على العكس نشوف في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بعض الامور انه ابنائهم يتكلموا
معهم في البيت باللغه الانجليزيه يعني
ويمكن هذه المشكله نجعل هلا نقول همم
الدوري الاسره هنا مفقود مو عيب انه انه
انه يتعلم اللغه الاجنبيه بصفه لغه عالميه
وهي اللغه رقم واحد لكن اعتقد انه مسؤوليه
اكبر كذلك يجب ان تكون على الاسر بلا شك
همم الاسره لها دور كبير جدا ان اتكلم عن
المشهد العام المام يعني المشهد اللغوي
العام هو مسؤوليه كبيره تقوم بها المؤسسات
اما على مستوى الاسره الصغيره فحتى يعني
كبار الباحثين كلهم كراش المسؤولين عن
اكتساب اللغه الثانيه يقول ان حديث الام
لابنها باللغه غير لغتها الاصليه هو عقوق
من الام الى ال- ال- الابن وتقصر في
واجباته وحقوقه ولهذا السبب تقول اليونسكو
انه عام 2016 قالت ان همم يعني اطلقت
مبادره كبيره سمتها التدريس الجيد
والتعليم باللغه الام لابد ان يكون
التعليم باللغه الالم حتى تكبر هذه
الانتماء لهذه الثقافه تستطيع الاسره ان
توازن بين اللغه الانجليزيه واللغه
العربيه اكبر معضلا وجهها تدور في كثير من
الالسن
الطفل يستطيع ان يكتسب اكثر من لغه ثم
نكتشف في الاخير انهم قدموا اللغه
الانجليزيه من ناطق العربي ام وابي
يتكلمون العربيه يقدمون لغه انجليزيه لابن
لا يتلقى الا هذه الانجليزيه فضيع مشيته
ومشيت الحمامه وهذا يسمى اصلا علميا
بالسيلينج ولزم الذي هو لا هو اخذ
الانجليزيه من اهلها وياخذها من امه وابوه
وله هو حافظ على العربيه التي تعبر عنه
ضمن العالم يعني والعالم يتغير انا اريد
يعني ان اقارن بين المشهد ايضا تابعته في
اليابان في 2003
كان المشهد انه هناك اعتداد كبير من قبل
المواطن الياباني ويرفض حتى ربما الحديث
معك بلغه اخرى حتى لو كانت اللغه
الانجليزيه همم عندما تسالوا عن امر ما او
عن عنوان ما يعني هذا المشهد تغير كثير
تمام يعني في زياره اخيره قبل عام تقريبا
اصبحت اللغه الانجليزيه تقريبا تقارب
اللغه اليابانيه احنا جزء من هذا العالم
يعني فبالتالي ليس هناك مشكله في ما يحدث
من ناحيه التطور التغير التحضر وغيرهما
جميل
طالب الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
اي دوله ناطقه اصليه باللغه الانجليزيه
يعطونه مقص فيقول له الوالد اذا ابوه او
امه اذا سافرت الى تلك الدوله وتحدثت
اليوم الدنيا ساقص لسانك يقصد انه ولدك ان
تمارس اللغه ولكن ان عدت الى اليابان
وتحدثت معي بالانجليزيه ايضا سوف مره اخرى
هنا ياتي الاعتزاز والتوازن الرائع جدا
بين اللغه هي لغه عالميه لا نكرهها سواء
في البحث العلمي والمعرفه والتطور وبين
اللغه الام التي همم يعني تحافظ على ارتك
وتاريخك واعت ذلك همم هل هذا الامر يحصل
على مستوى العالم وانه امر طبيعي نعم لكن
هل جهود من الان همم تعتبر كافيه للموازنه
بين اللغتين اعتقد ان نحتاج الى جهود اكبر
وتوعيه اكبر جهود يعني على المستوى
الدبلوماسي على مستودعم المملكه للغه
العربيه في الكثير من الفعاليات والمنظمات
الدوليه ليونسكو وغيرها من الامور ما يكفي
هذا الامر انا اعتقد انه الجهد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه خارجيا تعتبر يعني
ترفع الراس ومشرفه لجميع الدول العربيه
خصوصا في القرار المشهور 3190 لليونسكو في
اقرار اللغه العربيه عام 1973 بان تكون
لغه رسميه وسادسه على همم في في هذه
المنظمه المتحده معاهد كثيره استطيع ان
اتحدث ثلاث ساعات عن جهود المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في دعم اللغه العربيه باموال
كبيره لا ترجوا منها الا تعزيز الهويه
لهذه اللغه وما تحمله من الارث لكن اليوم
اذا كنت تدور في في كثير من المحلات تجد
كثير من همم يعني النشاطات التجاريه تكون
محليه ونشات محليه ولكنها باللغه
الانجليزيه تجد كثير من المسؤولين او داخل
الاجتماعات او ايضا في البريد الالكتروني
في الاجتماع باللغه الانجليزيه لا يوجد
احد يتكلم عربي عفوا انجليزي الجميع يتكلم
عربي باستطاعتهم ان يواصل الحديث باللغه
العربيه الا ان اللغه الانجليزيه اخذت
مكانه وحموله بانها لغه تحضر ولغه تقدم
وهذا في المؤشرات اللغويه بالمناسبه يسمى
الموقف اللغوي الاجتماعي ما موقفنا اللغوي
من اللغه العربيه اليوم هل نراها يعني حتى
انا دائما اقول مثال طريف تسمع اللغه
العربيه اليوم للاسف في جنوب الرياض ولكن
لا تسمعها في شمال الرياض تسمعها في محل
الفول والكلاب الاكلات تسمعها في المطعم
الفاخر جدا هذه
الازدواجيه تعطي سرديه همم سيئه عن اللغه
العربيه وكانها لغه لا ترقى لان تكون في
الاماكن همم الرفيعه الشان شكرا اللغويات